-It is time to play
a game of deception
called "True Confessions."
♪♪
My first opponent tonight is
a multitalented actor, writer,
and comedian whose new HBO max
special "Marlon Wayans Presents:
The Headliners"
premieres tomorrow.
Please welcome Marlon Wayans!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. Wow.
You just kind of -- Wow!
-I'm going to win this one,
Jimmy.
-You just came right in. Looked
Like a magnet brought you in.
-That's right 'cause
I'm here for business.
I'm winning this one.
I've been on this show 17 times.
I haven't won nothing.
This is rigged.
[ Laughter ]
-Marlon and I will be facing off
against an amazing actress
who's currently starring in
season two of "Russian Doll,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Please welcome Natasha Lyonne!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Natasha Lyonne!
So good to see you.
-You too.
-You look great.
Now, here's how this works.
In front of each of us are
two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true. The other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then we have to come to
a unanimous decision.
Is it the truth or is it a lie?
Marlon, you'll go first.
Which envelope should
Marlon open?
One or two?
-Sir?
-Yeah, what do you think?
-I get to choose?
-No, I think we'll choose.
Right?
-See, it's already rigged.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
What do you guys think?
What does the audience think?
[ Audience shouts "two" ]
Two. Everyone's saying two.
-Okay.
-So crazy you think
you're going to win.
-Yeah. It's interesting.
-I am going to win.
I once told Tupac that he had
eyes like Snuffleupagus.
[ Laughter ]
-There's no way, man.
There is no way.
-There's no way that he could --
What year was this?
-Oh, uh, this was in the '90s.
I remember we had baggy pants on
and, uh, he was still rhyming
like, "Hey, B, see me."
[ Laughter ]
-Where were you guys?
-Um, we was -- Where were we?
-Yeah, when you were with Tupac.
-We was at Glam Slam
in Los Angeles.
That was Prince's old club.
-I don't know, man.
-Glam Salam?
-Glam Slam.
-Oh, Glam Slam.
-Yeah.
-Was it like a tennis thing?
Like with also glamour?
Glam Slam?
-You know, Glam Slam.
You know, Prince, he liked --
-Glam.
-Yeah, glam and he liked slam.
-Now I understand.
-So you were at Glam Slam,
which is like a club,
and you're sitting
next to Tupac.
-Yeah, it was me, him,
and Biggie.
[ Laughter ]
I got to put my glasses on.
-Yeah, yeah,
put your glasses on.
Wait, so you, Tupac, and Biggie
were sitting together,
and you lean over to Tupac
and you go,
"Your eyes look like
Snuffleupagus"?
-How long are y'all gonna
ask me questions?
[ Laughter ]
Yes, I told him --
-What was his reaction?
-I'm so sorry.
I have a follow-up question.
What does that mean
when someone's eyes
look like Snuffleupagus?
-This is what the card says.
[ Laughter ]
I think because he had
very long eyelashes.
-Oh, I see.
-Like Mr. Snuffleupagus.
And he also had
really soft hands.
And I called him
the Palmolive Thug.
[ Laughter ]
-Did he go crazy?
Did he freak out?
Or was he laughing?
-And what was Biggie doing
this whole time?
-Biggie was just -- it was
all -- [ Snoring ]
He was just breathing.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know 'cause Marlon --
I've seen him in action.
He's a very popular guy,
very charming.
-Oh, he is. He's a wonder.
-I could see him go to parties
and I could see him actually
saying to Tupac that and --
-And getting away with it.
-Yeah, and getting a laugh.
Snuffleupagus-like
eyelashes but --
-And yet I think it's definitely
the truth.
No, I'm just kidding.
It's a lie. It's a lie.
-We think it's a lie.
-I got you, Jimmy!
It's the truth!
-What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No way!
-Wow!
-What?
-No way.
-Tupac and I did "Above the Rim"
together.
I went to see Tupac and Biggie
perform at Glam Slam.
We was all sitting around
cracking jokes,
and I told him he had eyes
like Mr. Snuffleupagus
'cause his eyelashes
were so long.
-Yo, that is a great story.
You got us.
Marlon Wayans, congratulations.
That's the way to do it.
-I won! I won!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No one ever --
First time you ever won.
No one ever wins.
-Do I get a prize?
What do I get?
-Bragging rights.
-This whole ashtray is yours.
-Yeah, you get the whole ashtray
of fake cigarettes burning.
Alright.
It is my turn.
Which envelope should I open?
-One, baby, one, baby.
[ Audience shouts "one" ]
-Okay.
-One.
-On Monday,
I was at the White House
and I helped the President
tie his tie.
-Mm.
Biden old. He need a little help
with them ties.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, my first question is
when was Monday?
That's what's tripping me up
here.
[ Laughter ]
-That's your first question?
Monday was this week.
-Today is Wednesday.
-So let's start
at the beginning.
-What time on Monday was this?
-I was there
for the Easter egg roll.
I went with my wife and kids.
We went and I read a book.
I didn't even know if I was
going to meet the President.
Then I met him and yeah,
then I tied his tie.
-Was he not wearing a tie?
Why were in his dressing
quarters?
-I wasn't in his dressing
quarters.
I was actually in the Blue Room.
You have to go to the Green Room
to get to the Blue Room
to get a photo
with the President --
-What happens? That's where
the President wears blue?
-What'd he smell like?
What'd he smell like?
Was it cologne, dentures?
-Old Spice.
[ Laughter ]
-Old Spice. Okay.
-No, no, no. He smelled great.
-Coffee breath?
-No coffee breath. He was there
with the First Lady.
And I walked out.
I was kind of nervous.
I was there with my kids.
He made a joke to my kids.
He said, "I don't know who your
dad is," something like that.
It was funny.
And then he stood up
and the First Lady said,
"Jimmy's tie looks great.
He always has nice ties
on his show."
And I go, that's 'cause I --
I go, "Thank you.
That's 'cause I know
how to tie a knot.
I know how to tie a good knot."
And he goes, "What's the
secret?" or something like that.
And I go, "I can tie yours."
-What kind of tie was --
Did you do a double knot?
A double Windsor?
What kind of tie --
-It's a flipover. I don't know.
-How many times you flip it?
-It's a two flip and then a push
through and a yank.
[ Laughter ]
No, I gave a nice tie
and it worked.
I couldn't believe
no one was stopping me
'cause I knew -- You don't
really see Secret Service
because they're kind of hiding.
But no one stopped me.
No one even said,
"Don't do that."
He's the one that loosened it
and took it all down.
And I'm like, "I'm gonna do
this," and I did it.
I tied the President's tie.
And then he went
and spoke to America.
-I mean, I don't not believe it
is, the trouble here.
-He's Jimmy. He's going to --
I would let him
if I was the President.
-If I wasn't the president.
-Now, if I was Obama's tie --
Obama like,
"Nah, nah, get up on me.
We good, we good, bro."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But Biden, he may take the --
I'm gonna say it's real.
I'm gonna say it's true.
-I think it's --
I think it's true.
Ah, it's gonna be a lie.
-I got you. It's a lie.
-Damn!
-Come on now!
I just made it up.
I didn't know
what story to tell.
They wouldn't let me touch the
President of the United States.
-Why not?
-I didn't know.
It was Secret Service.
-Were you even there?
-No, I wasn't there.
No, I was there.
I was there.
-Oh, you were there.
-I was at the White House
on Monday.
But I just figured it'd be
some type of story
that would happen to me.
-You're a good liar.
-Alright, Natasha,
it is now your turn.
-Thank you.
-Go for it.
-Which one?
-I think number one.
Number one.
[ Audience shouts "one" ]
-Alright, alright.
-I know it's season two
of "Russian Doll"
but number one, come on.
-The first time I ever flew
on a plane,
Marlon Brando,
my close personal friend,
we worked together with
on "Scary Movie 2,"
was in first class,
and he brought with him
an entire birthday cake to eat
on the plane.
-Did he share the cake?
-He initially did not want to.
I don't know if you know this,
but Brando's birthday is
April 3rd.
I'm April 4th.
So, you know, we would stay in
touch, and he would -- anyway --
-Too many details already.
I feel like you're getting
a little nervous
and you're starting to give us
too much details.
We didn't ask
what birthday it was.
-I just wanted you to know that
we have a similar birthday.
-Where were you guys
on your way to?
-Oh, yeah, good.
-He was on his way back
from Australia
because of [Laughs]
"The Island of Dr. Moreau."
I only laughed 'cause it's
your favorite movie.
-Yeah, I do like that movie.
Val Kilmer.
-That movie,
you're always texting.
-I always say I love
"Island of Dr. Moreau."
All the Marlon Brando --
That and "Superman"
are my two favorites.
-And I always say,
"What about 'Apocalypse Now?'
and you always say,
"It's about Moreau, baby."
-Yeah, it's about Moreau, baby.
So, you said he was flying back
from Australia.
And you what? How are you --
You greeted him in the plane
on your birthday?
-I like flying, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, I think this is
off the rail.
The question is, is Natasha
Lyonne playing us right now?
And purposely saying --
-Guys I just -- Marlon.
I want you -- look at me.
-My name is Marlon, okay?
So I'm trusting
my Marlon instinct.
I knew Brando too.
-We knew Brando.
-Yes.
-I have those dailies.
-[ as Brando ]
Does he talk like this?
-You knew him --
Y'all met on the set.
-Did we? Did we?
-[ Normal voice ] How did you
see him in first class?
Were you in first class
as well?
-No.
-Oh, you don't think
I travel first class?
-No, you do!
Of course! Of course you do!
-Not back then. Not back then.
-In '96 during the filming of
"The Island of Dr. Moreau"!
-Oh, okay. Well, maybe.
-Wow!
-Was you in that movie?
-Wasn't I?
-You just look so young.
-Thank you.
-Wait, so he got in.
You said,
"Hey, Marlon, good to see you."
And he goes [as Brando] "It's my
birthday, it's our birthdays.
Would you like some cake?"
Or he goes, "I don't want to
share cake."
-Alright, fine.
You know why it's weird?
I wanted to sell you on the fact
that he gave me cake.
But you know it's Brando,
he likes a snack,
and no, I didn't get any cake.
-So You already tell half a lie
'cause you said
he gave you some cake.
-Okay whatever,
but that's not what's
written here.
I was trying to make it seem
Like --
-First class, he brought
a whole entire birthday cake
with him on the flight.
I'm gonna say...
I don't know, man.
Honestly, I think --
-That's too obscure
not to be real.
It has to be real.
-I think it's true.
Did it happen?
-To me?
-Yes.
-No way, baby.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Come on. Come on!
That is a pro!
That is a pro right there.
That's a good one right there.
-The only non-liar,
Marlon Wayans, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Natasha Lyonne.